c'est un maire qui attendait une
décision ferme de la justice j'ai tout à
fait confiance en la justice j'espère
que les le jugement sera à la hauteur de
la violence de l'agression le procès
c'est une chose la confrontation est
importante mais le jugement c'est
l'étape qui pour moi est certainement la
plus importante un élu soutenu par les
habitants de sa commune et des maires de
cô d'or venu pour le procès les
habitants d'Ouge sont ont été très
choqués de ce qui s'est pass surtout que
c'est un village vraiment très calme qui
qui est vraiment connu pour ça et de
vivre ce qui s'est passé là c'est
quelque chose qui a marqué les esprits
c'est inacceptable qu'un élu soit
agressé c'est inacceptable qu'il faille
tant de temps pour juger des voyou qui
ont agressé violemment cette élu
solidarité totale avec Jean-Claude
Girard le 23 mai 2021 Jean-Claude Girard
interpelle un conducteur de quad qui
roule vite dans sa commune après une
altercation le conducteur appelle des
amis à lui il s'attaque alors au maire
et à une autre personne à coup de barre
de
fer sur le banc des prévenus cinq DESC
mises en cause des jeunes d'une
vingtaine d'années pas toujours à l'aise
au moment de s'exprimer et qui disent
être dans le flou 2 ans et demi après
lesffit à la barre Jean-Claude Girard
raconte lesesséquel psychologique
toujours présente je suis marqué pour
très longtemps même pour toujours à
chaque fois que je passe sur les lieux
j'y repense l'avocat du maire évoque lui
la désinvolture des prévenus je n'ai
entendu aucun regret c'est désespérant
de se dire que tout ce temps n'a servi à
pas
grand-chose finalement un seul
s'excusera pour l'agression je suis
désolé je ne voulais pas faire peur mais
après 2hur de délibérer tous sont
condamnés des peines allant du surcis à
8 mois de prison ferme c'est une
décision GIS pédagogique qui est ferme
et et qui rend justice puisque il y a
SEP mises en cause qui ont été reconnu
coupables de l'agression du ma dououge
rappelle quand même que la plupart
plaidit la relaxe c'est-à-dire leur
absence totale de responsabilité ils
sont bien bien reconnus coupables le
tribunal a quand même entendu certains
de nos arguments en effectivement actant
que ces jeunes gens n'étaient pas venus
pour en découdre spécifiquement et
surtout pour en découdre avec le maire
il reste 9 jours aux avocats de la
défense pour voir si leurs clients font
appel